In addition to choosing
a unique name for your app.
Another thing that can
help people search for
your game is to include
the right keywords.
Keywords are words that link your
game with certain search terms.
>> And then lesser game is top ranked.
Keywords will be the main way
that players find your app.
But how can you decide on the best ones.
The best keywords are similar
to the best names.
They describe your game well and
done up in searches quite often.
>> Lots of developers choose
to mix highly searched words
with more descriptive ones.
For example, they might use
common words like game and
fun alongside more descriptive
words like lasers or penguin.
>> Yeah, and
once you have chosen your keywords
you'll want to move on to building great
visuals with icons and screenshots.